good afternoon my name is Adrian check
and I'm an associate professor at the
Barrow Neurological Institute and I'm
going to talk to you today about the
ketogenic diet as an adjuvant therapy
for malignant brain tumors if you have
any questions please feel free to type
your questions into the Q&A box which i
believe is on the left of your screen
and i'll need to get to them during the
talk or at the end of the talk in
addition this is a cme accredited talk
so if you want CME credits you can click
on a button on your screen and you'll
get credit I do have to give a brief
disclosure in that is that some of the
work I'm going to discuss was supported
by a grant from nutrition North America
and they provide kita Cal that we use
for these studies first a few brief
survival statistics about brain tumors
brain tumors are a leading cause of
death due to cancer in the pediatric
population in adults there's a peak of
incidents in 02 19 year old people and
of course another peak of incidents in
the older population as is normal for
most cancers and you can see from these
statistics that the survival is really
very poor and the survival is with the
standard of care that means radiat up
that means surgery radiation and
chemotherapy in the case of glioblastoma
multiforme a one problem with brain
tumors is they're very heterogeneous
that is if you look at the cells from
different regions of the same tumor you
can see that when you grow them in the
lab they can look different if you look
at the karyotypes that I'm showing here
you can see that at the genetic level
cells from the same tumor can be very
different at the molecular level the
cells can be very different and in fact
that means their phenotype in other
words their behavior their invasive
capability their response to therapy etc
is also different and this is all within
the same tumor this makes treating them
extremely difficult one thing about
cancer in general that's been found in
the 1920s and is sort of resurfaced as a
hallmark for cancer is that cancer cells
tend to have aberrant metabolism there's
something called the Warburg
offices and that came from otto warburg
in the 1920s and he said that cancer
cells undergo aerobic glycolysis in
other words cancer cells have used high
levels of glucose and glutamine for
energy but they get fewer ATP molecules
than a cell normally would in the
presence of oxygen so they need lots of
glucose and glutamine to get the ATP
they need and the remainder of the
carbons are catabolized to make the
building blocks that they need for cell
proliferation virtually all cancer cells
have aberrant metabolism in one form or
another anka genes which used to be the
main buzzword for cancer a number years
ago they often regulate downstream
targets that we now know are involved in
metabolic regulation so oncogene
pathways are not just growth factor
pathways separate from metabolism but
the two pathways actually intersect and
overlap and metabolism often control
some of these pathways so if tumors use
a lot of glucose can you possibly starve
tumors by simply reducing the glucose
and this is where the ketogenic diet
comes in and to call it a diet is really
almost a misnomer because it's actually
metabolic therapy and don't do this at
home folks this is something that really
requires the assistance of a trained
professional it's a very high-fat
low-carbohydrate low-protein diet it
reduces blood glucose and it raises
blood ketones and ketones can be an
energy source for the normal brain so if
you reduce blood glucose the brain
becomes unhappy because the brain wants
glucose if you provide an increase in
ketones the normal brain and other
normal cells can use that for energy
tumor cells generally thought not to be
able to use ketones for energy and thus
you're basically starving them for of
energy this mimics chloric restriction
our fasting and it's been used for years
as a treatment for refractory pediatric
epilepsy so it's got a very long safety
profile and there's a lot known about
the side effects which are typically
handled with over-the-counter remedies
it's also thought to be neuroprotective
so it's being looked at for Alzheimer's
disease and other neurodegenerative
diseases and this may be due to the
reduction of reactive oxygen species but
there's probably other mechanisms that
are involved as well
so what is the potential clinical
utility of the ketogenic diet and
oncology well as I said before tumors
may not be able to use ketones isn't as
an energy source normal brain and in
fact normal cells can so you can be
protecting the normal cells from energy
reduction while hopefully reducing the
energy available to the tumor maybe this
will slow the tumor growth in the case
of brain tumors brain tumor patients
often have seizures this is known to be
an anti-seizure treatment so it could
possibly reduce seizures and brain
tumors patients in addition one
hypothesis is that because it's known to
be neuroprotective perhaps and this is a
hypothesis perhaps it would protect the
normal brain from radiation damage and
it may protect the normal brain from
some of the damage that sometimes comes
from chemotherapy when we first started
doing this we recognize that the
standard of care for glioblastoma is
surgery radiation and chemotherapy and
any additional treatment is going to
have to be done in the in the presence
of the standard of care so alterations
in metabolism really will need to be
done as an adjuvant therapy if it's
going to get to the clinic and that was
our goal first thing we did was we
showed that using cell culture and this
is actually a cell line that is very
autocrine that is it makes growth
factors spits it into the media and uses
it to help itself grow so it's it's a
cell line that grows extremely well it's
also grown in a very high glucose media
so these cells were not restricted in
their energy source at all and you can
see that just mock treatment the cells
grew quite well when we simply added
ketones to the media it reduced the cell
growth the patient the cell line came
from was treated with PC in use so we
tested me seeing you bcnu you can see
slows the growth and then the cells that
are resistant begin to grow again but
when we added me seeing you and ketones
together we essentially killed the
culture so this first gave us some
indication that ketones are actually
having an effect on brain tumor cells
not just because of a reduction of
glucose but also through some other
mechanisms we've recently looked at
whether ketones work with radiation in
vitro this is the work of a high school
student
laboratory alex rossi and we found that
again control cells grow well control
cells given radiation slows their growth
when we use beta hydroxy butyrate which
is a ketone it reduces their growth and
beta hydroxy butyrate plus radiation
pretty much wipes out the cultures so in
vitro this seems to work what about in
vivo we have an experimental protocol
that we've used for all of our in vivo
studies the GL 261 cell line is a
syngeneic mouse malignant brain tumor
cell line it recapitulates many of the
many of the things that you see with a
glioblastoma multiforme a we made these
cells bioluminescent with the luck to
gene and these cells are transplanted
into the brains of albino c57 black six
mice so we've got a sim genetic
immunocompetent model that we can follow
tumor growth using bioluminescence the
ketogenic diet that we use is kita kal
ki Tikal is a human formulation of the
ketogenic diet we provide it to the
animals ad libitum so we do not co work
we restrict we let the animals eat as
much as they want for humans this can be
considered a nutritionally complete diet
although it's typically used more as a
supplement or as a base for recipes it's
got a four to one ratio of fat to
carbohydrate plus protein and this is
again a ratio that's typically used for
pediatric epilepsy and what we do is we
mix it in the two-two-one paste with
water and provide it to the animals on
day zero the animals have the cells
surgically implanted into their brains
on day three we image them to determine
the tumor size they're randomized to
treatment protocols and then we check
the blood ehb or ketone levels and the
blood glucose levels and these animals
have a reproducible set of symptoms
approximately 24 hours before they
succumb to the disease so when we see
these symptoms the animals are humanely
sacrificed and that's what the image
looks like when you do the individual
imaging the computer gives us a color
picture but we also get a quantitative
number of photon count to tell us
exactly how much by luminescence there
is and that is the
I just okay hopefully you saw I just
pushed out a reference to you the
references are on the bottom of the
screen so this is what the growth curve
looks like you can see that with time
the tumors grow and the in vivo photon
count shows the tumors getting larger
the little inset there shows a brain
immediately after sacrifice of the
animal and you can see that the
bioluminescence is coming from that
little dark circle which is where the
tumor is bioluminescence requires ATP so
essentially it only shows living cells
the little instant we got we were able
to get only because we imaged
immediately after sacrifice had we
waited 10 or 15 minutes we would not
have seen bioluminescence so this is an
indication of live tumor cells and
following tumor growth you can see that
animals fed the standard diet the tumors
grow quite quickly that little drop at
the end is probably due to necrosis
happening in the tumor so the tumors
you're starting to see some cell death
and the tumors when they get very large
but the animals on ketogenic diet you
can see the growth rate of the tumors is
quite a bit slower so what's the
mechanism of this the first thing we
thought to do was to compare the
mechanisms of the ketogenic diet to what
we would call druggable targets in other
words things that the pharmaceutical
companies are looking at again to help
make it more receptive more accepted in
the clinic the first thing that we
thought was growth factors play a very
important role in the growth of brain
tumors there's quite a few
pharmaceutical companies trying to come
up with inhibitors of various growth
factors so doing a microarray analysis
we found that insulin-like growth factor
was indeed reduced in tumors from
animals fed the ketogenic diet in
addition to downstream targets the raspy
21 protein and map k8 were also reduced
this was at the RNA level at the protein
level insulin-like growth factor was
indeed reduced you can see on the
left-hand panel the left side of that
picture is a non tumor containing brain
the right side is the tumor there's a
great deal of green fluorescence for the
insulin-like growth factor and the
counter stain is Daffy
equally I on the ketogenic diet panel
you can see the tumor there's a lot of
nuclei together in the tumor side the
non-tumor side again looks pretty normal
with the nuclei spread out but there's
little if any insulin-like growth factor
showing another thing that we found
interesting was that other growth factor
is important in brain tumors for example
platelet-derived growth factor epidermal
growth factor pathways they also use
raspy 21 and map k8 so it's quite
possible that the ketogenic diet is
dialing down the overall activity of a
number of growth factors in these tumors
okay as I said before we use kita Cal
because it's clinically relevant we
previously did some of the work with an
animal ketogenic diet which is actually
a six to one ratio the results were the
same with kita Cal the results actually
are better as i'm going to show you in a
minute there's a lot of recipes out
there it's much easier for patients to
use if they want to supplement there's
absolutely a liquid kita cal version so
we now do all of our experiments with
kita cal so we repeated some of the
experiments we had done with a mouse
ketogenic diet and we've shown that
using kita cal the panel to the left the
black bar is the ketone level in the
blood on standard diet the blue is on
ketogenic diet and then the red and the
green are standard in ketogenic diet and
animals that got radiation therapy and
the gray and the purple are the ketone
levels and animals that got temozolomide
therapy you can see that the key to cal
does indeed increase ketones when we
look at the glucose this was somewhat
interesting we expected to see a drop in
glucose in the animals on kita Cal and
early on in the experiment six days
post-implantation we did see that in
animals that were on diet alone or
animals that were on diet plus radiation
we didn't really see much of a drop in
glucose in the animals on temozolomide
and we went two weeks into the
experiment approximately 13 days later
the difference in glucose disappeared in
the radiated animals and in the
temozolomide treated animals and it was
less of a difference in the diet alone
we can't really explain that but we find
it very interesting in light of the data
that i'm going to show you in a moment
the animal weights just to show that
they don't lose weight on kita Cal the
top bar is the diet alone you can see
the animal weights are the same in the
middle this is the animal weights in
animals fed standard diet plus radiation
in red and sorry in green and kita
Callen radiation in red the asterisk on
the green is one animal so where the
asterisk is showing there's only one
animal that is surviving at that point
that animal for reasons that we don't
know calorically restricted herself she
dropped her weight she stayed healthy
active showed no indication of a problem
and that animal did outlive the other
animals that were on standard diet plus
radiation so caloric restriction is
effective but we wanted to show that the
key to Cal was effective in the absence
of caloric restriction again the idea
being what's going to make it easier for
patients the animals on temozolomide
showed a transient drop in weight and
then on kita cal and that weight then
came back up so here's the survival
plots and this is why I think it's very
interesting that we didn't necessarily
see a major change in glucose but we did
see a difference in survival the black
line is animals on standard diet and
this is a combination of two totally
separate experiments so we had two
different experiments and we we pulled
the data to get these these graphs
animals on kita Cal had a significantly
increased survival temozolomide increase
survival over standard diet alone but
kita Cal plus temozolomide increased
survival over time azolla meinl room
with radiation again an increase in
survival over animals on standard diet
alone but what we really found
interesting was that animals fed kita
Cal and giving radiation actually we had
a tumor disappear in 9 of 11 animals so
using bioluminescence you can see in the
top panel that's an animal that got
radiation alone and you can see that the
tumor did indeed grow and the animals
all died the lower panel shows one of
the tumors that we have that disappeared
and they all disappeared with time
them a little bit sooner some of them in
about day 40 or so the block bar which
is a difficult for you to see possibly
but it's right at about day 101 that
indicates where we switch these animals
back to standard diet and these tumors
did not come back so switching animals
back to standard diet we waited another
200 days so the animals survive till
about day 300 and there was no
recurrence of the tumor upon sacrifice
the tumors could not be found so we were
interested in in how this is working
since the literature said that the
ketogenic diet reduces reactive oxygen
species we did one early experiment
looking at reactive oxygen species and
it looked like there was a reduction in
reactive oxygen species in the animals
fed the ketogenic diet when we looked
shortly before the animals to come to
disease we thought maybe the reactive
oxygen species actually peaked early and
then came back down so we used a
chemiluminescent molecule called l0 12
so that allowed us to measure the
reactive oxygen species in vivo and you
can see in this panel that the tumor
does show an increase in reactive oxygen
species over sham-operated animals as
expected this is what we found in our
tumors when we looked at 24 or 48 72
hours post radiation at all time points
kita Cal plus radiation reduced reactive
oxygen species relative to what was seen
in animals with radiation alone so
although the ketogenic diet seems too
strongly potentiate radiation at this
point we don't think it has anything to
do with reactive oxygen species and in
fact it's a little bit of a conundrum
why it reduces reactive oxygen species
and does not reduce the the efficacy of
radiation but this also is giving us a
little bit of a suggestion that perhaps
it would protect the normal brain from
damage due to radiation but again that's
just a hypothesis at this point the
other thing we noticed was that the
tumor size at death in the animals that
were on kita Cal tended to be bigger
than the standard diet and this is a
size based on photon count so it's based
on bioluminescence the thought is that
if what's killing the animals or where
people for that matter is essentially
tumor burden you can think of tumor
burden
as the tumor cells but also anything
else going on around the tumor so any
effects of inflammation any effects of
edema all of that essentially increases
tumor burden and because our brains are
surrounded by a skull there really isn't
any room for things to swell so all of
that contributes to the pathogenesis of
the disease and the the mortality of the
disease so if we have more
bioluminescence in these animals
something else must be less and we
hypothesized that perhaps there was less
edema so we do have an animal MRI here
and this was done in collaboration with
doctors Greg Turner and Chang Ching Wu
and we did MRI on animals two groups
that had tumors of essentially the same
size they did an analysis of the MRI MRI
and in fact there was a significant
reduction in edema in the animals that
are on kita cal versus the animals on
standard diet looking at possible
mechanisms of this cyclooxygenase-2
expression was the was one thing we
looked at we had a hint that
cyclooxygenase-2 was reduced from some
RNA data we did using the animal
ketogenic diet so we repeated this using
the human ketogenic diet or the keto Cal
and in fact you can see from the
immunofluorescence here the green being
cox-2 that in standard diet there's
quite a bit more cox-2 expression than
there is in animals fed kita Cal and in
these panels all we're showing is the
tumor we're not showing any normal brain
next to it so kita Cal seems to reduce
the expression of cyclooxygenase-2 which
would lead to a reduction in
inflammation in addition we have the
ability to look at this in vivo there is
a game fluorescent probe put out by
perkinelmer called Zeno light and it
shows cox-2 and you can see the
fluorescence of cox-2 in the mouse head
there so looking at a number of animals
some with radiation and some without the
key to cal reduced cox-2 expression in
animals that were just on the diet
standard diet in gray cuticle in blue
but also when the animals were radiated
there was an increase in the expression
of cox-2 as you can see with the red bar
and that's expected with radiation but
the animals on kita Cal did not see an
increase in cox-2 so the cox-2 levels
are kept down in animals on kita Cal
again suggesting that we get
reduction in inflammation and possibly a
reduction in concomitant reduction and
edema the other thing we looked at was
hypoxia hypoxia is common in brain
tumors there's usually areas of hypoxia
these areas are typically more radio
resistant because the radiation works
better in a toxic environment as opposed
to hypoxic again there is a a
fluorescent marker that we can use
called hypoxia sense which detects
carbonic anhydrase so looking at our
animals on the standard diet and on kita
Cal you can see in the panel below on
the left that the key to Cal
significantly reduced hypoxia in in
these animals based on the hypoxia sense
analysis and the panel on the right just
shows that we were looking at a group of
the tumors that were approximately the
same size looking at gene expression in
a more quantitative way by western blot
you can see that the cycle the carbonic
anhydrase nine which is a marker for
hypoxia is significantly down if one
alpha which is gene expression that's
increased in the presence of an epoxy a
significantly down nf-kappa b which is
which is a molecule that's involved in a
number of pathways including some of the
pathways that are involved with turning
with hypoxia and various other aspects
of tumor growth there's no difference in
total NF Kappa B but there was a
significant difference in phosphorylated
or activated in at kappa b and this was
work done by a high school student in my
lab Roger lotsa we looked at
angiogenesis the green fluorescence
being cd31 which is marking blood
vessels you can see in the standard diet
the blood vessel showing in in the tumor
in kita Cal that's just a representative
screen none wasn't shown and what we did
was we quantitated the amount of green
fluorescence in ten random fields for
standard diet and paquita cal and you
can see that there is a significant
reduction in cd31 immunohistochemistry
showing in the blue bar relative to the
animals on standard diet which is the
white bar
again Western blot recapitulates the
immunohistochemistry so we were
interested in the mechanism in
discussion with one of our colleagues
dr. Tom seyfried he said that with
caloric restriction he was seeing a
reduction in vascular endothelial growth
factor we weren't seeing that in some of
our early RNA data so we went back with
the key to Cal and looked again at
vascular endothelial growth factor which
is a a driver of tumor angiogenesis and
we did not see a reduction in our
animals fed kita Cal on the other hand
when we looked at the receptor vascular
endothelial growth factor receptor-2 we
did see a reduction so there is a slight
reduction in bed Jeff on the left but
it's not statistically significant
whereas it is statistically significant
difference in veg F receptor the graph
on the right shows the expression at the
RNA level of veg f a b and c veg if a is
thought to be the driver for
angiogenesis veg FB the activity of that
is not known really well yet in terms of
what it's doing in tumors but it was
interesting to us that it is
significantly down and veg FC there's no
difference so we think that the
anti-angiogenic mechanism going on here
maybe more related to the receptor than
the ligand again looking at other
markers of tumors for example maitra
metalloprotease looking at invasion we
did an experiment and I'm not going to
show you the data but we did a
experiment called the scratch assay
where you can grow cells in a monolayer
scratch the monolayer and then watch how
long it takes for cells to fill that
scratch that can be an indication of the
cells migrating or invading into that
scratch we did see a difference when we
added ketones to the media so using
western blots we looked at maitra matrix
metalloproteinase-2 and you can see that
the pro version of the unactivated
version as well as the activated form
both are reduced in animals on kita cal
versus animals on standard diet
I showed you the MRI that there was a
difference in edema so a demon
inflammation often go somewhat
hand-in-hand we looked at a number of
mechanisms that may be involved in edema
the other thing that happens in brain
tumors that leads to edema is the new
blood vessels that are made the
angiogenic blood vessels tend to be
leaky the blood-brain barrier
capillaries which are normally very very
tight get loose and they they leak and
that tends to increase the edema around
the tumors so we looked at some of the
markers of the blood-brain barrier
including zol 10 gluten and then
aquaporin 1 and apple porn for there was
a significant increase in so one which
would lead to a tighter blood-brain
barrier in other words more
normalization of these blood vessels we
do not see a difference in occludin but
we did see a apparent but not quite
significant drop in aquaporin one and a
significant drop in aquaporin for these
markers are also being used to look at
prognosis and brain tumors so
essentially the changes that are
happening would if this was the primary
tumor it would push it to a tumor that
had a better prognosis so these these
changes again are all good for the
patient so in summary of what I've shown
you essentially what we're seeing with
the ketogenic diet is a reduction in hip
1 alpha a reduction in phosphorylated in
at kappa be a reduction in veg f2
reduction in maître matrix
metalloproteinase so one aquaporin for
some of the genes involved in
inflammation and data I didn't show you
is we've got a reduction in tech so
essentially what the ketogenic diet is
doing is it is changing gene expression
possibly leading to a reduction in
angiogenesis tumor cell invasion and
Vascular leakiness and edema so
obviously these are all really important
things in terms of managing your brain
tumor so the preclinical summary should
the ketogenic diet be tested in the
clinic first of all we've demonstrated
that it has efficacy as an adjuvant
therapy it
tenchi ates both radiation and
chemotherapy in our mouse model there's
efficacy in the absence of caloric
restriction would there be efficacy in
the presence of caloric restriction I'm
absolutely certain there would be we are
doing all of our experiments in the
absence of glory restrictions simply to
make it easier for the patient to use it
easier to get patient compliance the
diet itself is somewhat restrictive and
not easy to stay on so we're trying to
make it as easy as possible to
demonstrate efficacy in patients we see
a reduction in peritumoral edema in our
model system a reduction in
radiation-induced inflammation reduction
in angiogenesis and potential value
added that we haven't studied yet but we
plan to is there's likely to be a
reduction in seizures and we think
there's a reduction in growth factor
signaling and network is in progress so
does the ketogenic diet have clinical
utility we think there's a resounding
yes answer there are case reports out
there anecdotal case reports and
published case reports the first one was
in 1995 when Lyndon ebling presented
work their data on to pediatric patients
both of whom were put on a ketogenic
diet and both of whom did quite well in
fact far better than would have been
expected from their diagnosis there was
a report at a at a meeting by Miriam
Colombian about a patient report a case
report about the young child with a
brain tumor and the ketogenic diet
extended that child's life quite a bit
and then in 2010 there was a report by
Zuko Lee and coworkers describing the
results on a 58 year old woman with a
butterfly glioma and again the ketogenic
diet seemed to extend her life more than
would be expected from the diagnosis
there's also a lot of anecdotal evidence
out there so if you go on facebook if
you go on some of these some other
public media there's quite a few people
that are saying they've done this and
it's helped so that's led us to go for a
clinical trial
clinical trial personnel we have is
leanora renda she's a dietitian that
works with our patients she's excellent
she did a webinar for the American brain
tumor Association if you're interested I
invite you to go on their website and
listen to it it describes the use of the
ketogenic diet for brain tumors Nerissa
honi dr. Nerissa honey she is a research
clinical nurse and she's doing quality
of life analysis and cognitive analysis
on the patients and quality of life
analysis on the caregivers doctors line
Ashby and Christopher Dardis are the
neuro oncologists at the BNI and of
course the Baron neurosurgeons are
strongly behind this the clinical trial
is for high-grade gliomas we're doing 20
patients with gross total reception 20
patients with a subtotal reception we're
looking at the ketogenic diet plus the
standard of care meaning temozolomide
and radiation using a standard protocol
so that treatment does not change at all
during the radiation chemotherapy the
patients are on a classic 421 ketogenic
diet it's administered by a registered
dietitian that's got training in the
ketogenic diet and that would be lorenda
or in our institution the patients are
doing this with normal food and Keeta
cal as a supplement if they want it the
diet is administered with the use of
something called the keto calculator
this is an online database it's HIPAA
compliant it's free the patients need to
get a prescription from their physician
there then registered on this database
and the dietitian and the patient can
then work together to make meal plans
and look at the different nutrients to
maintain the ketogenic diet in a healthy
way and through the use of the kita
calculator Lee and the patient can work
together in calories and amount of food
is altered as needed for the patient to
feel good and maintained ketone level
and glucose levels where we want them
we're looking at the tolerability of the
diet we're looking at overall and
progression-free survival of the
patient's quality of life of the patient
and the caregiver because this is a bit
of a lifestyle to have to change food
preparation so one of the things that
were
you hear from people who haven't done
this is well it'll be too hard for
people it turns out that the patients
that have been on this many of them say
they can actually do this and it gives
them the feeling that they're doing
something to help themselves and that's
really important for patient quality of
life we're looking at changes in seizure
activity and anti-seizure medications
we're looking at changes in steroid use
the neurocognitive tests as i mentioned
are being done on the patients we're
doing daily blood ketone and blood
glucose levels to monitor the diet
effectiveness and determine if
alterations are needed so the goals that
we have and have the ketone levels above
three preferably around four and glucose
at about 70 now a number of brain tumor
patients end up on steroids because of
swelling first of all we're hoping that
the ketogenic diet will reduce the need
for this but also it can be very
difficult to maintain low glucose levels
in the presence of steroids I'll show
you from some data that I'll give you in
a few minutes that one of our patients
was on that and actually was able to do
it so it might be a little more
difficult but it's not impossible the
patients are monitored for uric acid
cholesterol triglycerides ldh acidosis
and free carnitine so these are the
cases we've had to date to these cases
are actually on our trial and three of
them are being followed outside of our
clinical trial you can see here the the
ages are ranging from 39 to about sixty
three two of them are not on steroids
for them are total follow-up is pretty
variable some of them have just started
one question that we always get that
people really worried about is weight
loss people get very concerned about
weight loss and rain in in tumor
patients in general and in fact the
weight loss that is seen on the
ketogenic diet is absolutely not the
same as the weight loss that's seen in
cachexia in cachexia is muscle wasting
it's it's a weakening kind of weight
loss the weight loss that we've seen in
some of the brain tumor patients as you
can see from these numbers it's
relatively minimal and it's not a muscle
wasting type of weight loss and in fact
the patients do tend to gain it back
we have quality of life analysis on one
patient again as I said this is done by
dr. Nerissa yoni and the t1 is the
baseline so that's before these patients
start treatment t2 is at the end of
their radiation therapy which is about
two months later t3 is four months after
baseline and t4 is eight months after
baseline something I forgot to mention
when I discuss the clinical trial the
patients are on the classic 421 diet
during their radiation chemotherapy when
the radiation ends we're allowing them
to transition to what's called a
one-to-one diet or a modified Atkins
diet this is a little bit less severe
but it still does help keep the glucose
a little bit lower and hopefully the
ketones a little bit higher so that
would happen right about at t3 you can
see from these numbers larger is bigger
and you can see if you just compare t1
to t4 that we're not seeing a major
change in quality of life the quality of
life of these patients is not going down
because of the diet in fact in some
cases it actually looks like it may even
be going up a little bit again cognitive
aspects of quality of life we're not
seeing a decrease through the ketogenic
diet weight status this was one patient
that did lose weight at first but she
regained that weight and her diet was
initiated at about 1,200 kilocalories
and it was maintained about 18 to 1,600
as best we can figure this the weight
loss at the beginning may have been due
to the fact that she was very fit did
quite a bit of exercise and when she
first got sick she stopped exercising so
there was a little bit of a drop in
weight but once she got strength back
and got back into one more normal
routine that weight was gained back you
can see that even though this patient
was on high-dose steroids her blood
glucose averaged at about 82 it went
ranged from 74 to 105 and the ketones
range from about 5.4 to as low as three
but the outside they averaged about 5.4
they went between point three and 7.7
and even at 7.7 she reported feeling
just fine
cholesterol was borderline high
potassium a little bit low the side
effects that you tend to get with the
ketogenic diet are usually manageable
fairly easily so cholesterol can usually
be managed simply by changing the source
of the fats and constipation is handled
with me relax increases in in calcium or
the are handled with poly citrate and
with that I'm going to just go to my
acknowledgments and open the open the
table for questions I'd like to thank
the people in my laboratory Eric wolf
and Ken Brooks mohammed abdul wahab and
Katie Fenton our students that have done
the majority of the work you saw Katie
curly was college student that did some
of it I mentioned some of the high
school students the de fork with us my
collaborators Philip Stafford Greg
Turner Cheng Wei Lou mark Poole and John
Rowe who first turned me on to the
ketogenic diet and then our funding
sources the first being a really awesome
group of students that work very hard to
raise funds and they actually supported
the work that I was involved with us
getting involved in the ketogenic diet
in the first place and with that I'd be
happy to open the door to questions
there's two questions I see typed the
first is those kita Cal have any effect
on tgf-beta and cytochrome C or a pop
Tata qu'avec in vitro or in vivo we
haven't looked at tgf-beta and we
haven't looked at cytochrome C so I
can't answer that with respect to a pop
ptosis we haven't looked at a pop ptosis
on kita Cal when we were using the
animal formulation that is the 6 to 1
ratio it didn't seem like it was a major
difference in the number of cells but it
was very interesting that a pop taught
Excel seem to be somewhat distributed in
the animals on the standard diet and
they seem to be a little bit more focal
in the animals on the ketogenic diet but
um we haven't actually looked at
anything quantitative the second
question is is that relate is that
effect related to tumor grades or
staging I'm not sure I know what you
mean if you're asking whether the the
effective kita Cal is is related to
tumor grade or staging our animal model
is
a model of high-grade malignant glioma
it's invasive and it shows a lot of the
hallmarks of high-grade tumors so the
effects we see there are not related to
grades or staging with respect to some
of the work being done in the human
population our clinical trial is all in
patients with very high grade tumors
there is some work being done in the UK
we're on patients with lower grade
tumors mostly if those patients have
seizures and if the seizure medications
are causing side effects some of these
patients are switching to the ketogenic
diet the seizure control and they're
going to be followed for their tumor
growth and progression-free survival so
if that doesn't answer your question
please just retype it are there any
other questions
well if there are no other questions I
guess I'll sign off if you think of
other questions in the future or you'd
like to contact us please feel free to
contact me you can see my email address
at the bottom of this I'm also going to
push out a few i'm told you should be
seeing a pop up with some reprints of
some of the work i've shown you these
are all available through PubMed and
through the various journals and with
that I'll sign off thank you very much
for your attention